Now completeness can be difficult to assess. As my
friend David Silverman is fond of saying, you don't know
what you don't know. Now in this discussion we're
not talking about individual fields missing from a record. Instead,
we're actually talking about missing records. That is to
say, trying to figure out when it's an entire record
that's gone missing. So the solution here is very similar
to the solution for accuracy. Essentially, we need reference data.
So, let me give you an example from something
I work with on a regular basis. I'm the director
of education at MongoDB. And part of my role, I'm
responsible for our certification program. Now, we do things a
little bit differently than some other technology companies, in that
our certification exams are delivered entirely online. So, in addition
to a completed exam record for every test taker. In
delivering our exams online, we have to have a way
of proctoring them to ensure the security of the
exam. The way we do that is through a web
proctoring solution where capture video of the test taker
session. We capture both video of the test taker themselves,
using a web cam, as well as screen capture
for everything that's going on on the test taker's computer
screen as they're taking our exam. What this means,
then, is that we have three separate data stores that
need to agree with one another on a couple of
different things. And here is where we get to the completeness
example. They must agree on the list of test takers, that
is to say, if there is a record for a test
taker in any one of these databases, there must be a
record for that same test taker in the other two. They
also need to agree on the duration of the exam session.
So the video, here and here, should be approximately the same
length and it should agree with the elapsed time that
we recorded for a test taker. And, of course, these
have to agree approximately. Within sum Epsilon. Now, you're probably
thinking what if somebody took an exam and the record doesn't
exist in any one of these three databases. Well, that's
exactly right. As I mentioned at the beginning of this, this
is a difficult problem to address because we don't know
what we don't know. In that case using the solution that
we just described we would not detect the missing exam
record. So, in point of fact, we actually do a couple
of things in addition to this to ensure completeness for our
exam records. And those are essentially preventative measures to make sure
that we can't get into a situation where we haven't captured
the appropriate exam data for a given test taker. So, to
wrap this up, as with much of data cleaning, the means
of auditing completion is situation specific. It really depends on what
the data is that you are auditing and what reference sources you have access to.